so speaking of god
you mentioned to me offline you're
wearing uh the the most sophisticated
clothing choice
um of the elite intellectuals uh like
you mentioned sam harris was wearing a
hoodie this is the sam harris hoodie
he's starting a trend he's starting a
trend
um this is a new religion you could even
say it's a ritual it's a ritual practice
of uh intellectuals of searching for
meaning
uh so there's there's a quite a
fascinating debate so he was for a time
still
um known as one of the sort of new age
atheists
so he was kind of trying to explore the
role of religion society
and the role of science and then the
other side another kind of powerhouse
intellectual is jordan peterson
who in um sometimes from my taste a bit
too poetic of ways is exploring the
ideas of religion
uh and would they have these interesting
debates that i think will continue about
the role of religion and society
for uh for jordan there's all these
flaws with religion
but there is
a lot of value to be discovered amidst
the the rituals the traditions the
practice the way we conceive of each
other because of the ideas that religion
propagates and then
for sam
it says that everything about religion
is uh basically gets in the way
of us fully realizing our human
potential which is deeply scientific and
rational and
sort of like we're surrounded by mystery
calling that mystery god is getting in
the way of us understanding that mystery
what do you think about this debate
about the role of religion and society
we should continue having this debate i
talked to jordan a couple weeks ago as a
matter of fact excellent and and his
podcast is public excellent it'll be out
soon
and so
you know he and i
how did that go by the way um it was it
was incredible uh carl rock the
professor joined us as a matter of fact
for one of his rare public appearances
so beautiful we went we went deep um and
jordan is very well read obviously on
the psychedelic literature he had just
had um roland griffiths from hopkins on
the podcast and it's one of roland's
figures that jordan and i again just
like the language of aldis huxley
it's hard to move past the following
statistic
over the past 20 years
of the modern study of psilocybin roland
will tell you that about three and four
of their volunteers walk away from their
single dose of psilocybin high dose
saying it was among the most meaningful
experiences of their entire lives if not
the most meaningful and jordan says like
how do you
what do you do with that um uh how do we
i mean how do we synthesize that um
you know here we are
quantifying the the qualifiable the
unqualifiable and and yet these these
compounds have dramatic effects on
people's lives and they walk away
feeling like they're more
loving more compassionate
the science of all talks about
the the welling up of cooperation and
resource sharing and kindness and all
these strange things from this single
chemical intervention which seems to
reduce us to automata as if
enlightenment can be flipped on uh like
a switch and yet there it is there's the
data and i don't see how you walk away
from that i mean i i completely
understand sam's position
but i think there's there's a reading of
religion
particularly the mystical core
of of the big faiths and especially
these ancient mystery cults which do
speak again to those moods and
motivations
um creating this aura of factuality that
these volunteers
never walk away from permanently
transformed just like the ancient
mysteries and part of that is perhaps
language that we need to continue to
evolve language in
in how we conceive of these processes
maybe religion has a bunch of baggage
associated with it
that um is good to let go of
or perhaps not i don't know it did
this is connected to our previous
part of our conversation is the
importance of language in this whole
thing well that's how i start my book
with one of these volunteers from the
nyu psilocybin experiments this this
woman dinah dinah bazer who's an atheist
and she still describes herself as an
atheist and yet as one of these three
and four people who walked away from
this experiment transformed she says
that her experience of psilocybin was
like being bathed in god's love from an
atheist yes and i asked her why she uses
the word god why not the love of the
cosmos or the universe or mother nature
and she says well frankly you know we
don't know about any of this stuff and
that god makes sense to me um she's
still an atheist
um but it's the way she describes that
as kind of like the way your mother's
love must have felt when you were a baby
yeah there's a there's a kind of i like
the way einstein uses god god doesn't
play dice there's a poetry there's a
humility that you don't know what the
hell is going on
there's a humor to it i'm a huge fan
especially like more and more
of just kind of
having a big old laugh at the absurdity
of
this world and this life
as uh represented nicely by memes on
twitter kind of thing
i mean there's a there's a sense in
which we want to be playing with these
words and not take them so
seriously and being a little bit
light-hearted
and explore
you